hi my name is tj i'm nine years old and
today i'm going to have two chefs
compete to make my dream dish
what's up big man
how's it going hi i'm marie
and i'm alvin so what do you think yeti
would eat so i think they would eat
rocks to sharpen their teeth uh i cannot
imagine how rocks taste like oh that's
that's a boulder oh wow it looks like
one of those neck pillows yeah on the
airplane
and then some hair on them because they
shed a lot you get a hair in your food
you send that thing back but today i
have to make edible hair intentionally
appear in the food and it has to taste
good and then i'm going to draw a bone
because they need carbonation now what's
animal that they come from a wolf a big
wolf
a big wolf
and then i'm going to draw the grass
what kind of grass grows in such a cold
climate yeah well this
grass is called
gracie
gracie spell it out
okay it's tough he has amazing
imagination then they can eat branches
from trees and then some leaves i got my
work cut out for me man this sounded
kind of tough
why it's your favorite food broccoli
broccoli
no way
really
the mystery oreo uh-huh it tastes
exactly like gingerbread so you kind of
like spice like cinnamon yeah i like
normal oreos rice crispy treats
apples sounds like tj likes sweet stuff
and i'm a dessert snob i want to try
coconut do you like it or you just want
to try it i want to try it i think i can
see the gears turning everything's
starting to make sense a little bit okay
tj do you think we can make it yes i
have good hopes in you oh me yes thank
you and you and you too oh thank you
thank you
[Music]
here's my plan for the rocks i'm going
to make chocolate cluster mixed with
bunch of different cereals and golden
oreo and oreos and cover them all with
milk chocolate for the bones i'm going
to make pak pastry cookies with cinnamon
and sugar for the grass i'm going to
blanch some broccoli and cut granny
smith apple into glass shape for the
treats i'm going to take pocky and cover
with candy melt and white chocolate and
i'm going to top with some sprinkles and
last for the hair i'm going to use
katafi dough and bake it and sprinkle
some sugar i'm going to make rocks out
of oreo truffles with a speckled white
chocolate ganache glaze for the branches
i'm going to make toffee trees with mint
leaves for the grass i'm thinking of
making a mint lime coconut crumble and
for the bones two simple shortbread
cookies and to top it all off some nice
chocolate curls for the yeti hair
all right are you ready i'm ready okay
let's get started first i'm going to
make
bones
and i'm going to cut out this puff
pastry dough
and shape like bone
so the dough is a little bit soft so i'm
going to put this in the refrigerator
smart that's exactly what a pastry chef
would do thank you so really's been on
the show she has experience you know how
this works she knows how to make kids
happy she's won twice in the last season
it's kind of a lot to try to go up
against i'm trying to make grass so i'm
gonna be zesting limes throwing some
mint in and some toasted coconut tj said
he never tried coconut so he might not
like it i think it's very risky decision
it's looking cool oh nice
oh that smells good oh it's like mojito
yeah cause it's like mint and lime i'm
going to make a brown ooh out of what
alto pocky
oh that's so smart oh my god
oh my god i think that i'm asian too
she has been known to be the coolest and
most professional and fanciest person
that i know so
i'm not really sure if i got a chance
here i'm gonna make pocky fancy
make it fancy i've known alvin for a
long time and he doesn't want to say it
but he's a very competitive person
all right alvin you're still in this
come on don't give up now i'm going to
make pokey sticks look like a tree shape
i'm going to use white chocolate
and candy melt so i got my candy melt
melted and i'm going to transfer to
piping back and pipe
onto pockets you guys see that technique
that's so pretty thank you rie just
casually just pipes these beautiful
trees on her pocky and i'm just like
dude what the heck man okay i'm gonna
start on my rocks out of oreos and then
i'm gonna go in with some cream cheese
oh yeah there we go
i food processed these a lot and they're
kind of warm as you can see they're not
holding their shape so i'm gonna squeeze
them to help them set up a bit now i
have my white chocolate melted so i'm
going to do the same
tj said that on the rocks there's yeti
hair it's brown apparently so i thought
it'd be kind of funny
to make the hair out of like chocolate
curls i'm going to put this in the
refrigerator and my branches we are
speeding through things
you know
we literally just started and i'm
already 10 feet behind
okay next step
i'm going to make a little glaze for the
rocks i think it'll give it a nice color
so i'm mixing some white chocolate with
heavy cream a quick version of like the
ganache i'm going to take this i'm going
to microwave it and stir it until it's
smooth looking pretty smooth i'm going
to tap in a little bit of this oreo
powder to give it like a gray
speckled look this is looking pretty
good actually i think this looks like a
rock so
this is done the oreo balls are freezing
and i'm going to start working on my
tree though it's nice and cold so i'm
going to
sprinkle more sugar on top i'm going to
sprinkle a little bit pumpkin spice so
i'm going to bake this for 10 to 50
minutes for the branches i'm going to
start with a whole stick of butter and
then i'm gonna go in with a cup of brown
sugar and then salt for flavor and then
we stir now i'm gonna make my
rocks i'm going to make cereal and oreo
my toffee's at 300 the perfect stage so
i'm gonna take it off and
let it chill out and then we're gonna
try to make some branches
okay so i have this idea where
i'm gonna make some trunks i have these
chopsticks
i'm gonna lay them down like that
we have our toffee here
oh boy please don't separate don't
separate i'm still figuring out what you
are doing
trying to make it into the shape
oh like a log yeah like a log it's not
turning out how i thought it was gonna
turn out why okay now i have to make
branches so i'm gonna try to take these
and just
paint is it gonna go
nope
this is so not what i wanted it to be
alvin is trying to make his toffee log
but it's not walking and he seems like
very panicking i've never seen that side
of him before what was i thinking toffee
dude alvin this is sugar work you're not
a pastry chef okay my bones are ready
and rie's bones are ready so
my bone cookie is exactly what i
imagined wow oh my god that's amazing
thank you
and don't mind me i'm just struggling
over here
i have no idea why the top is being so
difficult i've made this like 400 times
before this one time i decided to make
it for a competition
it's not working it's coming back
together i added some water so now i'm
getting more of these like branches kind
of going for like a drizzle back and
forth technique
now i got my branches hopefully there
i'm gonna start placing these little
mint leaves that i picked out i never
seen you such like in a panic mode you
are always like calm
and like everything is under control
everything is not an extreme
in my bowl i have oreos golden oreo rice
crispy honey nut cheerios corn flakes
and cinnamon toast crunch okay so it'll
look a lot better once it comes out of
the freezer so i'm gonna take these in
and pray that they harden up to be a
sugar mixture that i can work with so
on to the next step
so my chocolate is melted
and i want to
pour into chocolate
oreo chocolate cereal
these are my rocks i'm going to reshape
them a little bit
because i think they spread out a little
bit it's kind of like
frozen play-doh it's malleable but it's
holding its shape which is great i like
to name my food
we're going to call this one carl i'm
going to call this one riye because it's
it's the best looking coolest one and
then we're gonna call this one we're
gonna name him bob
i like bob
and i think we're gonna glaze this
ganache wow
it's looking looks like rocks
wow
i'm pretty proud of that look at that
that's pretty cool that's so cool all
right
back into the freezer we go this is
exactly what i wanted in my head the
color's there the sheen is there the
speckles are there these are some really
good looking rocks yeah the rock looks
really cool i'm a little bit worried
okay so i'm actually going to get
started on my bones while my rocks and
my branches are in the freezer never
thought i'd say that but first we're
going to start with butter
and sugar i'm going to cream these
together
liquids egg
vanilla
i chose shortbread because i didn't want
it to spread too much to finish off with
the dry ingredients so we have
corn starch this is actually going to
help absorb
a little more of the liquids so that the
shortbread doesn't spread as much we
have powdered sugar for sweetness and
two cups of flour
that was looking pretty good
so i want to shape this rock into neck
piro a neck pillow like tj said on the
plane so i'm going to put in a
refrigerator let's make some bones
first
let's start with the middle
i'm going to make my grass tj mentioned
he loves broccoli so i'm going to brunch
some broccoli so i see rie pull out the
broccoli i remember tj saying that he
loves broccoli if rye's broccoli wins
her the prize i'm gonna be so mad yeah i
made four bones uh hopefully fifty
percent of them are usable
um riya gave me a look no i'm not sure
but these are going in for 10 minutes at
350 and
fingers crossed
well i'm going to i'm going to start
making whipped cream okay i kind of want
to hand do it so i have some cream and
then i have vanilla and then a little
bit of honey
okay so this
is beautiful it's luscious it's done
broccoli is done
so i'm going to add a little bit of
olive oil
and salt
and we are ready to plate okay oh you
have a big one plates i'm going for a
more rectangle i think this represents
like the rocky side of a mountain yeah i
like that i kind of like the texture on
it it's just
this is the biggest bone i've ever seen
in my life come on
and i broke the bone so we're not using
that one uh yeah i guess that guy was
calcium deficient good thing i have
backup but now i am 200 miles behind
wow look at that
are you gonna brulee it torch it
oh
this is a great idea you gave me a clue
oh i wasn't gonna do it thank you oh of
course yeah of course you helped me i
helped you this is how it works what did
i do i'm pretty just kicking myself in
the butt here man like what helping
reach doesn't even need help
oh yeah i didn't even need it look
oh wow look at that tree
we get to the plating this part in my
head was the toughest part because of
the
i don't know really what trees do with
this
tree tree tree
yeah so the branches are actually sticky
so the branches aren't gonna work but
i think i have a solve i'm just gonna
use the trimmings from the trunk to make
the branches adaptation improvise adapt
overcome oh wait i have an idea let's
see if this works
whoa that's cool
all right let's stick with that oh no
yeah let's go baby so instead of doing
this dumb branch thing i did i'm just
gonna
split the tree like a lumberjack and
bend the branches to the way i want well
this looks so much better than the
original idea i had
that looks like a tree right yeah all
right now i just have to reapply the
leaves
wow it's working i'm applying my new
knife technique to the trees they're
coming out great my confidence is back
up again after a big beating and i think
i have the shot at this i am very happy
by this turn of events one accidental
knife stroke and you get real trees yeah
i've decided to cut up all
like grass heat draw
wow that looks amazing
really you am i missing anything no
right oh hair
i can't believe i forgot no way
wow such a good idea
so this is basically a shredded
philadelphia it is used in middle
eastern deserts a lot all right i'm
going to move on to the rocks now the
rocks in the wild i think usually
there's like grass around them so i'm
actually going to lay a bed of grass for
the rocks i'm going to put some butter
so i'm going to bake this for 375
fahrenheit for 10 to 50 minutes
it's looking better than i thought it
was it's got my hair whoa it's so golden
yes it's like the crunchy fried noodles
you get in like chinese dishes sometimes
i like the color because he put like
brown so he wanted hairs
i'm gonna just put hair on top of my
rock yetis have to sleep somewhere i
think
if they were to sleep they'd sleep on a
nice bed of snow i think this whipped
cream can
represent that so we're gonna give him a
little bed over here it's also snowy in
the mountains so i'm gonna dust it with
some powdered sugar to look all the cool
yeah good job good job we did it yes
i put all pj's favorite food on the
plate and made exactly look like tj's
drawing i'm very confident that pj will
like my dish
i'm happier with my dish than i
originally thought not everything went
according to plan but i think i was
pretty close to the drawing put some
nice twists in there i hope tj is as
excited as i am when he sees the rocks
cause those things are pretty dope man
bring on my yeti meal
oh my goodness
oh i like the broccoli and the trees and
this one exactly looks like this one
it's
cool my attention to detail is paying
off oh my gosh this is pocky i want to
try this one
yes he loved pocky
it's kind of like vanilla frosting i
love pocky mmm i like the cheese yeah
broccoli florets
[Music]
mmm
i like the broccoli part i love broccoli
are you kidding me the broccoli oh my
oh this looks like cinnamon
[Music]
i didn't put some on that
it's made of oreos
i love the rocks it's so good
tj is literally loving every single
thing on rie's plate
it looks like a really
giant cookie
mmm this is really good
oh i think this is like the grass the
grassy
[Music]
i've never even had a granny smith apple
and i liked it i liked everything on
this plate he said he loves everything i
made
this is gonna be a tough act to follow
oh
wow this looks cool my dish goes in
front of tj his eyes go wide i feel like
i'm still in the game i like it how they
have this rocky texture because they
live in the himalayan mountains
oh the rocks look amazing as well
it looks like ice cream with cinnamon
and is that like crushed up broccoli
yeah it looks like crushed broccoli he
is literally getting everything wrong
and i love the bones they look like a
dough like cookie dough this white thing
is not on my drawing but it looks
amazing oh this is hard
it's good it's good it's like a sugar
cookie
this smells weird but i'll give it a try
follow me
[Music]
it's oh it's fine it's fine
i know when a kid is lying all right
i'll try this plane
whoa that thing is soft
i think there's a whipped cream
let's go see
hmm
final thing
is
the ice cream it's not ice cream my guy
but that would have been a great idea
wait this is not ice cream
it's a cake i think it's a cake
broccoli with cake
tastes good no it's not broccoli it's
coconut it's green it's green coconut i
made it for you man yeah it's broccoli i
think it's broccoli
out of everything i like the rocks the
best the trees were kind of hard to bite
through
but the but it still looks like the
drawing
all right so tj you had two yeti dishes
the first one was on a round plate the
second one was on a rectangular plate
which one did you like more the round
plate
good job riya wins i guess that was kind
of expected i had a lot of fun competing
against her but hey the queen of tasty
is still clean and as a reward you get
this thank you so much we now win a
chicken bone dinner good job
good job thank you appreciate it
sometimes you cannot beat experience
[Music]
you